education experts say distance learning  has added  extra challenges for students who live  in underserved communities  discovery children's museum is trying to  change that they opened a free study  hall so that kids  don't have to go through distance  learning alone they select up to 50  students from title 1 schools to take  part in this program  a free study hall is providing socially  distanced steam education lessons  discovery museum staff will provide the  in-class support for virtual learning  such as answering questions  and keeping students focused on their  work if you'd like more information on  this  just go to discoverykidslv.org